greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by Fuji Sports calm let me tell you
something my favorite DS that's all I
wear is [ __ ] food you had a nice
beautiful blue element on myself today
you understand me
they got a great new super rod oh and
they got a great new competition geek go
take a look Fuji sports that calm if
you're a fat [ __ ] a-five a-six let me
tell you something bro
people always try to pull you down from
the guard from behind the hole they
could tug on that thing for hours
nothing happens to that Fuji [ __ ]
gate dependable been around since Jesus
love Chicago plus they got [ __ ] mats
on getting granite Renzo Renzo Gracie
mats they got [ __ ] G's they got
[ __ ] kickboxing and stuff they got
kettlebells than a rubber like they got
a bunch of great stuff but you gotta go
to Fuji Sports calm right now press in
church band and get 10% off right now
[ __ ] number two listen you're
getting in shape you're trying to get
your life together you got this get some
supplements alright on it's the way to
go whether you get in the alpha brain or
the shroom tech sport
you cannot go [ __ ] wrong do you
understand me
we'll talk about it more in length later
on but right now go to on a.com impress
in church oh [ __ ]
Church get 10% off delivered right to
your [ __ ] house you didn't have
to go nowhere
kick that [ __ ] muley what's
happened it's a beautiful day to be
alive I got the flying Jew aka Christ
killer number one and I got my main man
Steve DeSimone it's [ __ ] confessional
Wednesday I think she wanna sit next to
me anymore
killer he lets it go it's crazy I was
telling me last night that I wanted that
be this weekend
okay this is your like listen as a comic
will [ __ ]
you're a [ __ ] hole then it comes a
time around the forty and then you just
want to do everything yeah that's what
it needs to do to make it happen but
then you have to tighten up your seat
but at some point in your career and
stop being a [ __ ] and that's when
things start happening yes and for me it
started by taking advice from others
you know I haven't listened to with
Jerome and have to say them hey if re
had a plug and a joke you know I trust
our yeah and I'm saying if I had a
problem with something a gig or
something you have to let you go down
yes a lot of times and I've known you
since the beginning we opening up for
dice 99 I think you were the first
person who put me on stage at The Comedy
Store open mic in 2000 yeah September
2000 October 2000 it's crazy how this
has been a journey for the both of us
and when I see you you know you're from
Philly yeah you're Catholic yeah never
seen the exit system you think you're
not seriously you run charities I mean
there's so many good things you do so
when I'm around you makes me feel better
like they have you wasn't one of the
guys that I went to martial art with
when I was up to 16 years old you decent
kids didn't really curse yeah they did
not drink they did not smoke pot I found
them entertaining and I enjoyed it yeah
but they didn't want to go get [ __ ]
like they were we were geeks yeah karate
geeks yeah and at that point you want to
go you want a finger I had two sets of
friends for a while I was trying to
sides of the fence
and the karate guys didn't know about my
crazy friend and my crazy friends didn't
know about my karate friends and then
they had to make a decision with that
yeah with the crazy people because the
karate guys I loved them dearly
right they weren't as much fun they were
there's much fun and save money and go
to Honda in New York and look at that
[ __ ] jeez yeah yeah help all
equipment
oh I'm rubber pads for your heads he
could beat each other up but it's so
weird how whenever I see you like I need
to talk to you and I know you'll give me
a straight answer you know everybody
this time well smoke up your ass yeah
and that's what happens to people Lee
and I were talking about a comic we saw
that that's just damaged from what this
town did to him it's easy to happen and
it seemed very easily because you know
it's so weird then when you used to open
up for Paulie yeah did you ever have a
night when people come up to you saying
you know what we're so happy we're here
you were so much funnier than boy yeah
but then you see them glow with a Paulie
and go Paulie is so great we love you
like look at [ __ ] people yes
so [ __ ] warming you I'm saying I
think that's part that was part of
Mitzi's logic to make us work the door
so we could get an appreciation for what
that audience was you get to see people
who they really aren't like so you would
have had that planet in the back your
head like are you gonna change who you
are to please these people because that
was one thing remember once I did a joke
in front of her she just goes you're
better than that
that's all she said I was like whoa she
goes I don't want to say it again you're
better than that
remember it's weird when you do a [ __ ]
up joking it kills a room and you feel
it you feel like an [ __ ] but this
weekend I went to tempie mm-hmm and this
has been I don't know I mean we've been
doing the podcast how long now five
maybe the second the year and a half we
had the guy kidnapped its College I love
when you call me kidnap be the kid that
be calling and I apologize to him I
sincerely meant that from my heart yeah
yeah they met that from my heart it's
crazy as it sounds guys there's a couple
calls I gotta make this sadly Matt had
like a nervous breakdown at my hotel
room about a different situation in my
life I have to take care of okay you
know I haven't like three of those blue
strings that I really have to take care
of forget my daughter that's never gonna
happen but I gotta open up the line of
communication my sister again yes the
phone call with my sister is a tough on
a phone call she feels cheated get him
Sam yeah she lost her mother a mother
left her there so she has a void in her
heart there's bringing issues when I
talk to her and it takes me three days
to get over yeah I gonna hang up the
phone I gotta have two more Dean he's
only been drinking martinis and so yeah
this family I grew up with the Jersey I
gotta call them so it's not a eat away
at me you know I'm a small school
Catholic I gotta feel guilty whatever
yeah and I want to make amends
you know mercy that came in Tanner life
so I've kept in touch with this kid in
the kidnappee dad keep talking told me
though and I call him and I asked him
how his mother's doing cuz that's why he
moved to Tucson
now and we talk you know what's a month
whatever so this time we talk up to the
point where he was coming to the show
Wow you know and then Thursday he was
coming and I didn't hear from him Friday
he called me you know it was a
kickboxing I called him back and he goes
my mother's been in the hospital
Jesus uh so I don't know if I can make
it tonight but I'll definitely see you
for dinner tomorrow night and then ever
heard from all day okay and I didn't
remember though in between the two shows
yeah and I gotta tell you some I went
back to my hotel room was kind of
depressed like I was really sad about it
and also I can wait a second why would
he want to come see me
yeah I [ __ ] kidnapped him and put him
in the trunk of a car for eight hours
that guy he probably had to go to
therapy for eight years because of what
I did to him why would he want to see me
yeah he was I'm like what the [ __ ] do I
think I had that this guy's a pop appeal
be my friend like he said let's go to
dinner or let's catch up but I got a
guarantee that before he gets in his car
he's like one of my [ __ ] crazy this
is the guy that put me in a [ __ ]
calling and put me in the hands with
some other guy who thank God he was
driving without his headlights on and he
got caught this [ __ ] [ __ ] bothers me
you know yeah but then I came to terms I
go what do I expect out of life that
people are just gonna forgive you that's
[ __ ] that they just viewing the
Bible at you that people really really
really gonna forgive you it's kind of
weird
you can't the way I look at it is for me
personally my job is to forgive that
doesn't mean I expect it from other
people
does that make sense like you I think
you're doing everything right with that
situation cuz you're even you're even
being compassionate enough to think
about things from his point of view do
you know what I mean yeah that it's got
to be painful for him and fear involved
there but the simple fact that you
created this relationship is a miracle
to me to begin with you know what I mean
and maybe there could be that legitimate
healing that legitimate like no but
that's the secret of life
you know I join the tables
I thought to myself wait a second
somebody put if I had two kilos of coke
yes and I have bodied you to my house
yeah and you robbed me well I want to
see that [ __ ] really like I actually
said that to myself
started laughing my ass off right here
in the morning and then I fell asleep
right by the way that's why I fell
asleep on the plane they had there
because I was [ __ ] tired like I
didn't sleep that night this was going
through my head I was sleeping at the
airport and out of the corner of my eye
I'm like that looks like skinny uncle
Joey you must have lost 20 pounds since
the last time I saw him yeah was
incredible it was so much fun this I
love that's my favorite thing about
being a comedian yeah and it's funny
when you go through certain gates people
go you just miss Philippe yeah you just
missed di ugly you just miss Colin it's
[ __ ] great right and it's crazy on
Thursday mornings it's 5:00 it huh me
sitting there sometimes and I would just
be silly I'll get there early eat
breakfast like it's 6:00 a.m. flight
7:00 a.m. flight yeah I'll get there
like it's I'll get there way before 6:00
me too and I get there like just get two
eggs sunny-side up I said a little
Mexican kind of joint uh-huh like a
doctor I think my blood pressure
medication hate my edible yeah Mexican
lady knows me already I cuz I sit at the
bar there's no drama
yep people have to wait long enough to
wait for a [ __ ] bar and you're there
by yourself there's a [ __ ] yeah I'm
there in the corner it's place when
you're walking on the right hand side I
know that's fun and I sit there
sometimes I see you know George Lopez
walk by then DL Hughley and the one
there so Eddie Griffin and it was great
it was great and well I haven't seen him
in years years like you just see a lot
of [ __ ] people but back to this
[ __ ] up forgiveness [ __ ] yeah it's
everything it's crazy
years ago I [ __ ] uh it was a
misunderstanding and I and I still feel
guilty about it this day because she
went through surgery over okay well we
were kids were riding bikes
this girl was writing took one of my
bikes and then we would live we were
living on Charles Court where I lived on
giving that terrorist but they lived on
Charles Court and the girl
that there was a bike thief that lived
next door to me and he would steal bikes
but he would mix the bike parts together
yeah I was like a chop shop for being
myself
he was chop shop for anything yeah the
guy was just brilliant he recalled was
it he was my age but he was very much of
a nerd he had glasses he's a dentist I
and he won't return my calls you love a
guy like it oh my god I put the [ __ ]
milk yeah but you're doing everything
you can do does that make sense
I thought he would call back because
[ __ ] but then I start about Hitler I
mean he's another guy gave him a bike
one day we used to be bike guys yeah I
always grew up a bi I loved everything
about bikes and told him I got the long
ball a bike he put the lawn mower engine
on the bike anybody yeah that one I had
the [ __ ] the Honda mini trail I had
the excel 75 done the 80 so 125 then I
bought a Kawasaki 175 then I had the
accident and then no more motorcycles
and bicycles in my life yeah at the end
of it but until that time I was a big
bike guy and this guy and Michael
Clements who his family had screw his
name you know the people that the whole
family's got twice nobody ate his
sister's [ __ ]
a sister was hotter than [ __ ] and she
lived he was a bike dude that was sober
like that a great kid Mike was a great
great great kid growing up yeah he would
come out of like if you were a little
kid he would come over and fix your bike
for you he wasn't gay and not the day he
was just a great guy we were about the
same age and in between us lived
Valentine and Valentine was the bike kid
okay that's thing I miss the damn just
now but he would jerk off over bicycles
like I had never seen anything like that
like if we walk through this big store
in those days there were two stores the
spec store the chain stuff I write the
speech style was Herman and his wife
and he was friends with my ding and my
t-cog Martin the fact oh my that was the
brother that was Herman dragon didn't
claim him because he was gay my mother
this is a TV show my mother was Friends
of Martin cuz he was a drug dealer and
he lived under the Garcias which I was
friends with like I grew up with the
Garcia girls oh the one Garcia girl
would forge my report card when I got
left back she's the one that would make
copies of my report card switch to grade
switch to grade number she was brilliant
she was already doing IDs when she was
in high school 16 I'm not gonna say her
name she's not [ __ ] doing IDs for
people she was that good of a [ __ ]
counter for this with wite-out and
printers and printer yeah you have no
idea what if I said like the report I
want freaks me I said she would change
unit election days straight A's aids B's
of B right yes you know no realistically
and then now she's not business no no
she's a married chick that was married
she came to one of my shows in Jersey
years ago and I have a phone I check him
with every six months married she
married a great great friend of mine I
went to medical school for 32 years
Wow like his family had so much money
yeah miss Fanny his mother was a doctor
who's and father was a doctor
okay they were famous Cuban doctors in
the city okay and these kids went to
like the Dominican Republic to be
doctors they just stayed on it just that
funny I just had party with the money I
mean we were kids he would just go
upstairs and take money out of a box
when I was a kid that was his mother's
room there was a silver box in the tang
what a combination of it and they had
the combination they would just go up
and take whatever they needed Wow we
were going to the city we go into
Hoboken and eat on 4th Street we were
gonna Hoboken when I was like 7th and
8th grade this guy's name was lefty and
he was picked me up in this car and wait
how old were you 7th 8th grade and he
probably was a junior in high school
okay and they had a car
and he hung out with this dude Sergio
Chi I mean they they were just a cruel
characters
yeah but lefty knew every cool weed spot
in the city like when I was in the
eighth grade
that summer yeah eighth the freshman
year he had a basketball court his
backyard and I pretty much that's a long
one would come like when you want to
[ __ ] play ball against the top
ballers you went to lefties backyard
that was happening like everyday let
everybody around like more clock people
and at that time there were two
all-americans from Hoboken New Jersey
juice and his buddy Charlie is so much
your Charlie was juice and there was
another one they ended up going to
Boston College Wow
Big East Big East and they would take a
bus to come play the score not lefties
and this guy could they have Hoboken led
the County and slam dunks that year when
he was a junior with both of them with
Julius they led the county and slam dunk
it was there was nothing better than the
high school saw the roof would blow off
a giant here's the crazy thing that in
high school this team was talent like
one of like it was like them
sacred st. Anthony's from Jersey City
clean a place was even established then
oh yes what's Hurley's dad the coach oh
yeah oh yeah and they had a kid named
rich Weinert who was my I know he was
six for 70 and then going to South
Carolina to a Gamecocks
Wow and that guy when I first went the
superstar basketball camp which was
Hurley's basketball camp and hey this I
wasn't apparently a basketball camp the
week Elvis died oh my god that same week
I still remember reading the paper like
that Wednesday I would take the number
one bus from North Bergen to Journal
Square and walk pass Hudson Catholic
where Michael Coren and Jim sponaugle
would I discussed this at that now at
this time these two [ __ ] from
Hudson Catholic were playing both of the
ACC which at that time was [ __ ] why
so Michael Coren was starting in at
North Carolina as a freshman Wow white
dude six foot seven
Jersey City boy and on the other side of
Duke his teammate was at Duke gym
sponaugle
Wow but not really for basketball he got
a scholarship for his [ __ ] coke
Wow mr. smart oh yeah yeah we discussed
this [ __ ] a long time ago I don't think
it was with you it's not yes so sacred
heart it was Hudson County Sacred Heart
and North Bergen and Hoboken and then
you had these tolerance who everybody
from Louisville at the time would go
from East darkness to Louisville they
would call it an out like a will reveal
connection gotcha
that guy would just recruit East Orange
all those black neighborhoods in there
yep
and they were [ __ ] flight remember
they went up against the team that went
up against houston with phi slamma jamma
yes and Louisville that yes for the
starters were from Jersey Wow like that
they called it the New Jersey connection
Louisville and [ __ ] but anyway back to
Lefty yep lefty when I was growing up
would take me into like it that's the
first person who ever took me into this
like I was buying weed in town oh yeah
hey we're gonna buy this [ __ ] come on
let's go into the city and I was a
Catholic I was a devout Catholic devout
this is when I first started losing this
is the first time I ever really lost
faith in Catholicism okay first time he
took me to a church mm-hmm in the
village he goes come on get out let's go
buy some weed and I gotta where we gone
you know we went to a basement of the
church the basement of the church it was
a bingo room mm-hmm
and there was a guy down there with all
types of weed like green weed brown weed
and in 1978 he used to sell this [ __ ]
that was like a brick mm-hmm and he
would it was like weed packaged and
dipped in hash oil that's how ahead of
the game this guy was plus he sold bars
of hash Wow and I'll never forget going
downstairs and paying for the reefer in
the hash I'm looking up in the priest
was in the corner the priest was letting
this guy shall we to take that as a as a
way to get money and I was okay that's
when I first saw things for what they
you know I'm saying I claim from a
fucked-up world yeah but now I'm
downstairs in a [ __ ] church buying
weed and you're a kid you're 13 I'm 13
and I was like wow the world was [ __ ]
rephrasing this is [ __ ] crazy I
didn't know nothing about pedophilia not
like that
all days I was an empty man that [ __ ]
about priests I didn't know nothing
about I never heard nothing yeah if
anybody was a pedophile was me so how
[ __ ] know I hate him saying I don't
[ __ ] know yeah but then you're
talking about the bike guy how you
tortured him no but I was trying to
think how come he never returned my
fault
yeah and him and I were like goombazz
like here because I knew he had that
twitch for stealing and everybody
thought he was just a nerd
okay the bike kid was at a twit outright
he likes stealing bikes and then they
would bring him home and he would kind
of apart and he would see what Michael
Clements needed that Michael Clemens
would see when he needed but Michael
didn't even know he was stealing the
bikes gotcha
so you then he would take the frame
sawdust the [ __ ] thing the serial
number off oh yeah he would put a tag
over it with a new suit
I mean he was tagging in the seventh
grade already and his and his bicycle
the choice was the one from one dorama
the Apollo or whatever the one with the
handlebars
like a chopper yeah like a chopper with
a [ __ ] [ __ ] bar in the back yeah an
annus he stole all those he would steal
one a day people be chasing the why he
got caught a couple times and beat up
like he would go on the neighborhood's
cut the fence jump the fence take the
bike and ten kids were chasing down the
fence they can't an operation he was a
[ __ ] savage this kid and then he
would take the bikes bring him back to
his house and switch the body part call
his tires so is a complete difficulty
looking bike and then he would sell it
to one of us mm-hmm or keep it for
himself he must have had 15 [ __ ]
bikes in his backyard and he lived
upstairs he was a tenant to the Ortiz's
there were Jehovah Witnesses we used to
torture them too we used to call him on
the phone and say that Bo they all wanna
[ __ ] I really want to see the TV show
where instead of the it's your version
of the Wonder Years
just as in that neighborhoods would be
the greatest thing on TV he was a great
kid never really got high and he was
raised by a mom the the people across
the street I always say that people next
door to me and I'm lying mm-hmm
this is weed because the other day I was
thinking about this I was thinking about
women what's going out with women yeah
yeah and I was thinking a little that
teach English on the show and we were
told when I was on the road with Sean I
was talking about that guy papi that I
know yeah at that time in the American
period in that in the 70s
yeah I really hate to say this the way
I'm about to say this but I have to say
there's just so people all where mm-hmm
you would see women with black eyes from
time to time mm-hmm
you would see women with fat lips you
heard domestic violence and you just
walked by mm-hmm and the 70s domestic
violence was still a little [ __ ]
secret mm-hmm and it wasn't accepted in
my house like my mother broke that
[ __ ] thing over one's head that was
it but the thing I saw one Christmas
like I got in trouble one time for
domestic violence and it really bothered
me this was when I was the [ __ ] kiss
a debt in 95 I was around somebody went
bad energy mm-hmm and I kept getting in
trouble with her one time and I'm
getting domestic violence I remember how
much it bothered me it bothered because
of the event I saw on that block when I
was like on the seventh grade there was
a couple who lived across the street
mm-hmm and one night we had to let the
woman in our house and the beaten her
husband had put on her I had not even
seen a boxer looked that bad like the
cops would have put this guy in jail for
20 years waited for this chick he burned
her with cigarettes he busted her head
open Jesus he [ __ ] cut her he punched
her lip party through missing my mother
had a threatening guy with a gun they
wrapped her up they put ice on her she
didn't want to go to the hospital she'll
[ __ ] side was purple he was younger
than me uh-huh and I remember talking
about that dude toffee from the
corporation's his wife Nina he would
throw ferocious beating it was part of
the lifestyle that you beat your [ __ ]
wife like that is [ __ ] absurd to me
that machee that machismo part of it
smacking a woman in the mouth or
something like that that's [ __ ] crazy
to me but it was something that was a
little hidden secret of America all
right Irish dad you know they were just
pounding on [ __ ] kids
ya know I know a family where the dad
was bound right kid I know a family with
up where the Sun was bouncing on the
dead Jesus I grew up with a [ __ ] kid
who used to be this data with his cane
Mike you're on I got tased him was
pretty funny he would take the cake to
be the wood [ __ ] you [ __ ] you how old
would you tell me tell me tell me um and
you want me to tell you some funny I
could call me about five years ago the
Big Daddy came there and he called me
and I think he remembered I had seen it
a couple times yeah and he called me
because I've been looking for a number
for a while my mom still says your money
but he does I want to call you because
my dad died like I miss him a lot and
now I know what you were going through
at that age and I can't even imagine how
tough you are for going through it yeah
and laying off the phone and remember
that his dad with a cane a couple of
times he'd beat him up with a [ __ ]
crazy
do I remember the first time I saw one
of my dad's my one my friend's dad's hit
not gonna hit compared to what you're
talking about there's nothing just like
a little smack in the back of the head
but I was about my parents and my
parents would yell but they wouldn't do
like I never got more than spanked
anything maybe some actor once or twice
will you yeah but I remember seeing a
kid get it anyway yeah like it shocked
me no I don't mind
but seeing a kid oh I've seen kids get
hit by their parents oh oh Jesus I lived
the neighborhood who I saw people get
[ __ ]
oh yeah bounce Oh chase time my mom
chased me one time with a [ __ ] stick
and she chased me and I may believe she
wasn't my mom that's a pool we were I
was a clown man Bowser
like a pool my mother told me to make
the bed the morning I'm not making a
[ __ ] bed I'm here if I [ __ ] didn't
gotta go back to beds here we go
well you're gonna take a [ __ ] why are we
gonna wipe your ass for if you're gonna
take a [ __ ] in our way they're right and
I would go I'm my [ __ ] making the bed
and she flop gated I'm at the pool like
with the chick fish thinking about the
ground thinking about the battles in the
Hill House I'm told y'all and I'm
sitting along and it's getting louder
and louder and also I see you by the
feds get out of that [ __ ] pool in
Spanish and I'm like who is this lady
yeah I've never seen the before my life
is she's crazy and I ran that way I got
out and ran that way and she chased me
oh my god are you nine ten no 13 14 this
is all yeah chicks meant some oh this
embarrassing I don't think me into deep
waters of embarrassment there was a guy
I call him mr. t no he was really racist
and every time I'd walk by the house he
go he went a nigga's cutting some
chickens up tonight he would always say
like the most racist things she would
probably expect in my face and then
become a friends ot no Miano manatee no
[ __ ] hate each other for years his
[ __ ] German wife is I hated those
people for years and at the end the last
two years we became friends and then I
would always after my mother died I
would knock on his door and he would ask
me how I was doing he had one tooth and
he was on his back he's criticized
everybody [ __ ] you you [ __ ] SPECT [ __ ]
I mean I just insult be right out every
day from the time I was 10 so I was like
13 when there's even oh I miss Dottie no
suck my [ __ ] dick [ __ ] and he
freaked
like he could have that in front of his
way like what you say spit go suck my
dick you want to [ __ ] throw down
[ __ ] and then what happened was
I think he was there that day my step
dad took the gunner against Albia razors
father
against ligo's a battle oh my god crowd
this is the story I'm getting to that
this is crazy this is miss Botti no
lived across from the Clements and just
criticized be and especially house were
Italian that's the only one he would
talk to so Dominick and Michael and him
would sit on their balconies talking
Italian about people uh-huh I understood
him cuz himself yes sir clusters I
understand what the [ __ ] they were
saying they had been talking about the
UH minigun and the [ __ ] [ __ ] a ruse
they would call the speaker ruse and
[ __ ]
sounds nice and I would walk past [ __ ]
wait your mom cut many chickens up
tonight or what like every night he
would torment me about Santeria [ __ ]
something like that yeah one two you had
one [ __ ] food down here he was bald
like he was going bald already he had to
be retired cuz he just sat on his back a
balcony all day and I used to play
basketball and I'd walk past me go I
don't know when you're gonna give that
up you respect you're never gonna be
bigger than five eight like he just say
race you lean crusher just suck my dick
how did you guys become friends finally
after I told him to suck my dick liked
anyway like know what happened was so
the story I'm getting to his Valentine
and the [ __ ] and the bicycle saw okay
let's get the Valentine first Valentine
was my Goomba to way you're my Goomba
yeah but Valentine was that Goomba you
had that always gets the tail end of the
[ __ ] stick yeah at the end of the day
his mother used to whistle for him yeah
that only he could hear it was like a
dog whistle
he could be in Secaucus in a swamp
dragging a motorcycle dog from a train
that we'd steal yep and long ago I gotta
go we go what a [ __ ] gone and you
just seen he would just tear as home
hear his mother's whistle she was going
and he was I can fly home he would stop
what he was doing his mother would beat
the [ __ ] out
so we were kids and then I had a the
first thing that happened was I bought a
motorcycle from Richie Vantage a Richie
vanish I got one of those bicycles that
I already had a Honda 50 and I had
already had an XL 75 and I already had
an 80 Wow but to be cool
Richie Vanna chick was selling his
lawnmower one that he had bored the
engine out so it was a strong it's like
a 75 Wow you know the old frame on a
normal bike trail and yeah the minibike
yeah the tube with the toothed little
tires and the whole thing and it was the
one that you pull the lawn mower you
feel it seems really oh my god little
baby kids and kids would just go fly
around the block but they explode
nothing nothing Jesus you would hear him
know we're on yeah yeah you would pull
the rope
and that's how you know you can tell
with people is like just a couple people
had those you would pull the rope and it
was an engine tied to a rope like this
and you'll pull it and they would spark
[ __ ] tremendously and you put gas you
go to the gas station to fill gas but
the cops couldn't see if the cops or you
get pulled over and they take it away so
you always riding some cops not
street-legal they what everybody would
say so man if you had a cop caught you
they would take him away or warn you
whatever so you were always on the
[ __ ] look out you were living like a
rebel at 12 yeah so I already had all
the motorcycles but Richie valincia
called me when he goes listen I'm
selling my the black one I need money 35
bucks so on Christmas [ __ ] Eve I
walked over to Richie's and gave myself
a Christmas present I bought Ritchie's
mother saying I think I'd trade them a
weed and a bike and I ride at home but
as I'm riding at home Richie goes bro be
careful this seat is not screwed it okay
you got to get it loose luck tomorrow
for the seat okay so be careful on the
ride home
so I ride the tank home to charge cord
up [ __ ] liberty whenever that Street
is and I'm making it on Union Turnpike
and I make it right up giving that
Terrace and there's someone in my garage
the windows start going up the storm
window the screen the window the other
wind on his head popped eyes what he got
a Valentine heard as he heard it he was
a motorcycle yeah yeah yeah what he got
all [ __ ] up coming now and he [ __ ]
slammed that thing that happy like 8:30
Colin is the Christmas Eve he comes down
and he [ __ ] oh my god we're gonna
have so much [ __ ] fun but I had just
note oh no it's no way three two days
early and all that was but the streets
were clean but there was black ice and
and the sides were like two feet of snow
- streets were clean yeah but you got
black ice is treacherous so he's a tall
man I can't wait to boil this out he
goes we're gonna take the top off and
we're gonna put a [ __ ] thing in there
you can see all of yeah he could see all
the potential but like what he wanted to
really ask me was Kenny lied and he ride
the [ __ ]
and he's like you know oh my god yeah
more than he goes do you mind if I write
oh yeah yeah get on the [ __ ] bike huh
so he I thought this [ __ ] was
just gonna like you know whatever that's
it yeah
North Bergen is known for him the second
heaviest town in the country Bell in San
Francisco okay every block is a [ __ ]
Hill that's why my heart is tougher than
debt because I walked those elves in
North Bergen and even have a fan page on
Facebook if you grew up in North Bergen
if you walk the hills in North Bergen
yeah no I do like this sliding mustard
when I went home a little now at home I
was talking to Dee they go do you how
many times you walk the Pet hill talking
mixing Gatorade and vodka as we're
walking up to the but we would run up
that hill
wow that's the shape we were in it was
amazing that 46 feet hell was a [ __ ]
monster
so Dini goes to the top DeeDee Valentine
Valentine goes to the top of the [ __ ]
Hill and I go Valentine be careful
because the seat so he goes to the top
of the hill he pops like a wheelie and
he [ __ ] murder and he's coming down
my pot and I want you to he's a good
rider you know yeah I'm watching it also
he's like 10 feet away he looks at me
weird because he hit black ice
which is not good of the secret attempt
the seat was the tats if he was on it
and almost amazing I made eye contact
with him as he hit the black hole and he
started losing could seem like he's
panic and it's his threat of eclipse the
[ __ ] and he squeezed the brakes and he's
hitting black ice
hey you just [ __ ] missed getting hit
by a car you didn't turn fight but he
crashed against Lucy small bushes wall
like the plants the cemetery flowers all
that [ __ ] I think he ended up getting
stitches on Christmas Eve I thought I'll
take a broken finger or broke like he
didn't snap his neck and my bike was
perfect I just picked up a walk at all
the seat was up the corner like this see
that flow it off what happened was he
hit something and the seat started
sliding Oh like this and awesome this
seat flipped behind the thing and his
arm is just he just let go the bike and
just let that guy let the bike go and he
just slid by and you could see is he
sliding on the ice this [ __ ] big
scrape on his back it was just a
nightmare the next day I saw him no I
got on the bike and all this [ __ ] that
was accident number one while I was
around me though his mother didn't
really like me his mom didn't like me at
all so now a year later I got a bunch of
daughter together and I go up to see him
Roebuck and I buy one of those [ __ ]
bikes and I bring it down the hill and I
rode it all the way from Sears Roebuck I
pull up in front of my house and they
had like the ring a bell or something
something that made a noise and he pops
his head up always [ __ ] yeah a new bike
he comes down again and he's looking at
he's like oh we're gonna put a [ __ ] bar
on this top of the thigh this like a
year later after this thing he's like
we're probably 12 or 13
[ __ ] no I'm young again I all he
wanted to do is take a ride on the bike
it had those what do you call those now
handlebars ah like this will you hold
them like this and they go like this
yeah yeah yeah yeah like it's like it
makes a big you you so he's on the you
again he goes to the top of the [ __ ]
Hill
it's the summer time the birds are
chirping the clouds right it's human
everywhere he goes the top of the hill
and he speed I already rode this bike
down a [ __ ] Hill I went to dirty H
Street Park and showed it off I wrote on
Union Turnpike I bring it home they
built it for me at the [ __ ] sea is
like I took it off the right wing that
time just give me the [ __ ] sample
nine dollars off or something three
dollars off and he gave me this a fuller
model before I just dying got time to
build it nothing oh no we still gotta
check it out so he checked it out I
wrote at home I get home and there's
Valentine and there he goes he wants to
ride the bike again he gets on the
[ __ ] bike again again he goes to the
top of the hill pops a wheelie and he
lands and he's [ __ ] speeding down and
I could see him my god and people I go
Valentine go he's like going and all
sudden they didn't tie this knot here on
stitches I pick up my bike Oh what about
the time of the fire what one fire it
wasn't I think a bug spray or something
that was the woods
oh yeah go on exploring in the woods
with some great as the woods behind a
house yeah so there was a soccer field
where we ended up robbing we robbed all
the tin metal off the truth there where
the people sat under like people would
sit there and watch soccer games we
stole all the metal one one by one with
a ratchet set every night
might need a devil via copper metal the
metal storage string goes like this
oh yeah metal sheathing types yeah yeah
yeah each of those sheets was 80 bucks
that's a grandma blow and [ __ ] $10 a
gas for each of us and we would go up
there with a ratchet set and take that
game what's going on like in the
offseason they came back in the season
you know what happened to our [ __ ]
roof they had to put a whole new roof on
I mean we took every sheet of [ __ ]
metal off that thing so and that took it
to Columbia lanes which was a pool hall
combination bowling alley they had the
best chocolate milk upstairs under the
machine the water the milk machine when
the milk came in bags and they would put
it in the thought you press a thing you
press the fan oh my god they would give
you you like a chocolate milk ice called
chocolate I haven't had a chocolate
melting with a [ __ ] 15 years destroy
it they would make this fresh with spoon
lovely you're robbing a place and then
still kid you like I'd like some
chocolate look right now but that was
part of the the soccer field had not
that the soccer field was should to the
field
it's a crazy German place is still bad
they do
big-time parties and they did soccer
back there and when you rode your
motorcycle back there a guy would come
out with a German Shepherd in the knife
his name was the chef he was the chef of
the place and he was a true Nazi he
would go back there yelling in German
get their [ __ ] slicing Kin Kin Kin
Kin Kin conk off my [ __ ] field Wow
and he would chase you off there there's
a couple times you chased North Bergen
baseball with practice there the Todd
brothers rich and Jeff Todd they would
practice there he chased him off there
with her life the guy was crazy Wow
so you had to be crazy and shits in the
field so we started going up there and
drinking and partying and [ __ ] yes you
get older so we started going up into
the woods and then one night it was the
winter so we would go to the woods get a
bottle of Boone's for him and wine hooks
of us would drink it and [ __ ] light
fires okay and every day the challenge
was to light the bigger fire okay you
know I tell and I brought a piece of
plywood I stole some gasoline from my
uncle we'd make a fire yeah I could
campfire we did this for about two weeks
we included Valentine
he gets up there one day he comes up
with a jar or one of these only bigger
okay it was this thing right here it was
a wife straw camp yep he brought a life
soft can of them we had the fire going
there's eight of us okay he goes watch
this guy's and he throws the life on the
fire what's it now for about eight men
how closer you guys to the fire
I mean the fire was right there when I
thought the clicker is where the clicker
is and we were surrounded around the
fire was wintertime and he goes let's
draw this in and see what happened as he
throws it in everybody's moving back
like a [ __ ] like rainbows coming out
not him he surround on top of it right
there about six seven eight minutes goes
by we forget about the [ __ ] and all
of a sudden you hear boom
let me tell you how life I saw the can
blow oh my god rapping and you see this
piece right here yeah this blue from the
thing and you saw it it went right in
the direction like I saw it like I was
looking at it walking back like going
this is not gonna be good
yeah walking back with me Dominic's but
shout got rest his soul it had to be
Louie the negev Louie and then there's
Carlos Perez it had to be a bunch of
those guys and I'll never forget walking
back and hearing the boom and seeing
something fly and Valentine was six feet
from the [ __ ] Jesus and the next
thing you know that circle was in his
leg ah and it was burning through the
jeans you could see the smoke already
because that they had burn no no it was
[ __ ] horrible guys it was all the
worst things I funny and bad at the same
time because this could only happen to
Valentine oh I mean he ran down that way
with that [ __ ] thing like it was like
a cattle prod yeah it was hot it was
[ __ ] on fire well he still the scar
because oh yeah oh [ __ ] yeah and dog
after that I can't really figure out
what happened between
oh my god oh my god Joey that's yeah I
looked them up I found them he's a
dentist but nah he won't reply how about
a shout-out for Jason who cheon's Joshua
Wesley Cornelius Burroughs Lorne Rosen -
my man Jeffrey Collins Andrew McCarthy
Christopher Court and Phoenix Xavier
glad song I love you [ __ ] don't
forget May 26th working out with uncle
Joey at the [ __ ] ice house don't
forget this weekend my little brother
Steve Simone at the Downtown it's in
south club in a party till somebody
farts oh my god I just bothers me that
like I feel bad yeah really true love my
heart feel really bad like you know just
say hello you know but one of the bikes
he sold me now didn't snow I was walking
out of my house one day I dated this
girl I fell in love in the seventh grade
with this girl she's [ __ ] beautiful
doesn't matter what her name is
and we didn't have sex or nothing like
we weren't even closed as I saw titties
one time you know she we were holding
hands and we'd watch done I was like it
was like the way Paulin hit my we would
hold hands and one Donny and Marie and I
would Donny go to the [ __ ] movies
with the grandmother I was an [ __ ]
yeah my first girlfriend yeah I thought
you gotta bring chocolates and flowers
and meanwhile I'm not getting any [ __ ]
I'm that's right bang her the [ __ ]
thing every night I'm like [ __ ] this but
we played hooky a lot we go
back to my house I'm Lea they call my
mother my mother just happened to be
home and once time they called so she
lived caddy yeah yeah my mother was in
the backyard and start calling her a
[ __ ] bulldog whoever raised that little
girl's a [ __ ] she's over Yuri damn my
son's bedroom and Marisa Wow we got to a
house and mother sadist and she goes
your mother is out of control the things
she's saying back there you know about
my house no more and all this [ __ ] and
pulled us all she was calling a [ __ ]
your daughter's a skinny hole Janice
Rossi yeah terrible it was just
embarrassing
and then we weren't allowed to see each
other and then it slowed down it ended
up we didn't date and I got left behind
and the whole thing hmm
and then we just broke up one day there
was no back at that time I was just
heartbroken yeah I got I was more
heartbroken I get left back there was
nothing worse than feeling stupid yeah
and I did it over a [ __ ] broad right
like I got so infatuated with her but I
forgot about Jia like I fell geography I
don't forgot what the summer school for
geography and math all right and like I
couldn't even resist her [ __ ] I all
right I stopped going to summer school
just to dry hump her be with her in the
daytime that's how weak I was you know
last week but that taught me like a big
like I couldn't let my mother know it I
got left back so I had to live on the
straight and narrow now so I had to
study every night
there was no reason why my mother would
have to get called to school I was very
gotcha I had to live for four years very
carefully now I couldn't know I quite
took my mother away from the game yes I
didn't let it know anything yeah no
reason to even know she kept asking me
what am i when you gonna graduate and I
said you know what I'm supposed to
graduate but one basketball camp instead
Johnson she's like am I gonna make me so
depressed I can't believe I'm gonna see
you graduate oh my god you'll be here to
see me graduate high school and I can't
get that going
the light just kept the whole its allies
work then I got into the freshman year
and
my god what is this kind of stop then
Sam we're like I always said in that
story when she when I found the dead the
first thing I came to my mind was I knew
she wouldn't find that I got left back
hmm like I just know wouldn't come to a
[ __ ] time
but New Yorker that was simply girl's
name we stayed friends you know we tried
to stay friends or whatever and then we
became kind of friends we all played
together I got over it yeah I started
going to karate I started playing
basketball more and I got back into the
string of things yeah and I forgot all
about it I'm saying I think I started
dating somebody else a girl that's dead
now god bless her so Helene cannot and
we were friends like just like a Long
Goodbye was friends with her brother you
know how it is yes and one day I'm
leaving the house and Valentin goes hey
man take a ride this bike it doesn't
feel right so sure enough when I hit the
left on the corner I felt that the
steering wheel wouldn't move fast enough
gotcha
like the string will need uh wd-40 and
oilers so I just took to think - Charles
Kourt and I went up the hill you know I
didn't stand up so if the chain broke I
would fall
I drank at all gently and then one up
Charles going I got to the top of
Charles Court and they were playing I
put the bike down Charles Court is one
of those streets that's a loop a
cul-de-sac yeah one of my eggs does have
an island in the middle core and a girl
lived in that house there was two houses
in the middle and there was a bunch of
bushes and [ __ ] the guy on this corner
was the guy that was working with the
Iceman oh my god that block was a hot
block that was the guy that was the guy
that taught Iceman how to use the poison
mr. Softee mister sloths mr. Softee
lived on Charles Court so we were all
planned charles court had Sabatino
Dean Hoffman those two kids that the
father was mr. Softee a Larese uh that
they had their own little community on
Charles Court yeah you didn't have to
leave Charles Charles Court had their
own kids that play with each other so
given that terrorists will go over and
play with Charles Court me especially
Al's Valentine Michael Clemons
and by that time they would they
wouldn't
in English to his face they would say
the Spanish Valentine no to Michael
Clements I was like when they took a nip
your house
that means Clemens has fleas hilarious
meets please how many times did he have
lice just once and he never the whole
family had and they lived they could
never live it down
[Laughter]
[Music]
because what they were out there playing
and Michael Clements gonna call my mouth
a no son Anthony god bless his soul do
so something get the hands on the
argument of about a bike I don't know I
was not there I was there but I wasn't
the yeah yes so it's a summer day ot
knows on the balcony yelling racist
stuff for people not easy before we
could Nelson lived there at the time the
pervert showed you if you watch the film
I'll show you I'll show you a Puerto
Rican Nelson lived as a nineties then
across the street was Raul Raul lived
across the street while they were moving
in me and Michael especially I broke
into the house so I had a stereo so I
stuck the stereo and I had it in my
bedroom guess what I became friends of
Raul so a row
come on my ass I won't let him rest in
my room my mom will go take my ot room
no I won't can't go in my room because I
had a stereo in my room oh my they were
moving in from the Bronx we robbed their
house and for years they can say this is
a terrible neighborhood we got robbed as
we're moving it as they move the house
across the street always had drama from
me they could never have the right rent
next to them was the girl named Grace
something and her sister
and they were really cute then and I'm
moving the titi neck when we were in
high school on the top of the block was
a girl named grace Savoia aka the onion
seeker savoia means the onion in Spanish
and her mother was hot hot mom Oh mom
and they were really sweet grace was
very sweet but grace is loved it was
having an affair with the like that hold
a man that was married and this is way
before Beverly Hills Cop dog this is
7576 while he was up there [ __ ] the
mom we put potatoes in his gasp oh my
god that was the given air Tara's like
Tim yang like someone can have he was
just guys it was just growing up it was
just growing up I didn't do anything
no no it's just growing up you can that
dancing crab that block I used to have
you see the backyard
and it was it was that block I was one
foot block inch thick blocks of concrete
you supposed to put concrete in the
middle of them yeah
my parents were Puerto Ricans they
didn't do that they just laid the block
down in the dirt yep and I put turn that
into a basketball court that's why I was
such a good dribbler but because it
couldn't trouble everywhere you could no
no no no you couldn't dribble on there
I figured out how to hang a basketball
court in my backyard and have three out
of three games and dribble on that floor
that was it was you'd be dribbling the
ball would jump out of your way I
figured out how to dribble because I
would dribble that but not only did I
have a basketball court
I turned into a pseudo baseball diamond
and I had the Green Monster but it
wasn't my yard the Green Monster was the
O'Rourke's yard next to us nice as white
people you ever met you know very polite
would bring over like Christmas cookies
and [ __ ] yeah
they could not take us we replace the
falls I'm always out kind of Spanish
music so I built a fake brick wall and
call it the green Buster when they went
on vacation
was there a fence between your backyard
- no there was a fence so you would hop
the fence and ha the wall over there put
the wall over there so you get a home so
we put we put an extra guy over the
fence and we his job is just a right so
I just took bricks and put them together
real bricks real bricks I cook them one
bed born from rental um but I think my
mine got him for me they deliver them to
my house and they put him in my backyard
me one by one I took each brick jumped a
fence with each brick I screw him over
and I built a wall that was probably
five feet but it was just made of brick
there was no concrete okay yeah yeah
made of brick that's not a very sturdy
no so I made it stay like this I don't
know how and one night will have the
soft me on my block Michael speciale he
had the worst act me ever seen he had a
pimple on this lip one time it was a it
was a white head around the black head
that had gotten infected all that had a
heavyset cheeseburger and a thing popped
one of us and you saw the pus on the
cheeseburger cheeseburger by God it was
disgusting he had pimples everywhere he
had the worst is the worst food had acne
as a kid that was torch room yellow his
back I said back and they were horrible
horrible whiteheads like that just stuck
out of inch like when you talk to Mew on
the palpable ya get that pop was let me
pop that [ __ ] zit on your forehead
like it was just a horror show he was
playing out for you one day and I hit
like a bomb and he's running towards it
my car is trim ski he's running towards
the wall and brother guess what this
[ __ ] does he tries to put his
foot up on the wall went through that
you should have seen the look on his
face all the bricks 1000 stitches the
whole thing yeah listen I talked to his
sister and his sister and me connected
out here 15 years ago and she told me
that she asked him if he knew many go
nope and I hope that's a lie she goes no
he makes believe why he doesn't know you
today Wow because the abuse on him was
so bad like he still liked me a lot he
only talks to one kid and his younger
brother died so he always blamed us
didn't blame me but I was on with the
brother when he died me and the brothers
a kid when that happened he was 16 the
brother that died was 16
Michael was probably 18 what was his
nickname I'm sad what did they call him
creature feature or something they
called him something so it's the sister
older or younger younger and she she was
about 5 when Dominic died hmm
so she called me from time to time we
always talk on his anniversary August
4th we went to THC crystal and he took
it one day you know with these older
guys and jumped in to not like a pack on
but the quarry is something in Jersey
that was always happened like there was
late 70s that stuff it was bad and he
[ __ ] drowned I still have a picture
of my li-- the camera from her Monday I
put a glass of water phone you know he
was my groom Bob but he got involved in
something and I stopped hanging out with
him like I just we all grew each other
over at offense/defense football camp
together we did a bunch of things
together
but the older brother hooked up below
he's quit high school he hooked up with
an older woman so when the brother died
he blamed it on himself not being there
but what happened Michael Clemons at the
end was that one day Anthony and him
Anthony died but I happened he was
always given two arguments and then when
a parent would come out Anthony we'd
yell at the parent and then when the
parent would say something to him and
him gone and get his father to beat him
up and it was classic and at that time
everybody knew of Carmine's reputation
miss the toughest guy my neighbor he was
a but he was the mayor's driver got him
out detective yeah and he was involved a
lot of people and they were lighting
fires so I used to call him the torch
because he had a go-go bar slash flea
market in the daytime it was a flea
market and then man it was a go-go bar
Wow
so it was known that he was good at
fires but one day they actually caught
me tried to let light the go-go bar on
fire and some kids are outside playing
they like mr. this smoke coming on the
building it's like there's no smoke
you're not saying anything is fine I was
a piece get out those kids won't happen
call the police and then they tried to
prosecute him wasn't he a police officer
he was a cop yeah and he still kept his
job any guy yeah cuz he faked a heart
attack
so you faked a heart attack I study the
role in jail and you don't have to
answer questions until you get out of
the heart attacks on you your attorney
that you would turn he up so he'd you
get in trouble you get a heart attack a
fake heart attack you hold it and you
[ __ ] oh yeah this was classic so by
this time he was notorious for he had
already beaten them mister Robson and he
did you guys see it oh yeah that's how I
became friends with the family oh I
remember you stood up for the kid right
Anthony right Lipper Anthony by mistake
like not knowing just from what I
learned and you moved there right from
New York I had lived there for about
maybe a year and a half and I had not
done to play with those kids I was
petrified of those kids remember that
those kids didn't look like the New York
City kids that I know they looked a
little harder a little weirder yeah but
once I got out there
like them I became friends of this
Italian family mm-hmm and caught you
know he anything he gave bro I did he
did a lot to me when I was growing up I
had a no-show job in a harvest man as a
janitor I had a no-show job in a park I
didn't dog he took care of me I gonna
have understood you're a family
I was faith you know I was telling him I
was telling me last night that his
famous words to me always were if you
want to kill somebody invite him over
for dinner and I was like eight and I do
like what the [ __ ] you thought he did
appropriate advice I met him when I was
10 my I met him when I was 10 from the
time I was 10 or 11 - [ __ ] after he
did it then he finally should invited
somebody to his house and he shot him
seven times in self-defense in October
of 83 he [ __ ] shot a guy October
Bailey to each other guys seven times in
the back and self-defense they found
that he ended up owning a half million
dollars that's why he shot they put a
gun in the guy's hand the guy lay them
down and carmine lost his job but he
never lost his pension wow this was a
crazy block he was the king of the block
oh but he lived on by the park but given
that Terrace belonged to him and Anthony
got into an argument mr. so it's a
summer day everybody's on the batter all
Italians everybody's on the [ __ ] bar
mm-hmm Michael gets into argument
Anthony everything gets into an argument
Michael's fall yesterday goes really
I'll run home and get my dad a little
[ __ ] further out he came back mr.
calm and handcuffed and beat him up in
the neighborhood in front of everybody
just started punching him like you see
in the movies huh with the handcuffs of
the guys yelling police brutality police
brutality and everybody started sweeping
not my business everybody on the bunk
started sweeping or they went inside the
house the only person was staying
outside was Opie no yelling in German in
the trip no the [ __ ] his nazi wife
was that the one where he had two
cruisers come up and they were writing
tickets to fake me about him and the
cops who come they'd write freight
tickets and then he and he beat him up
handcuffed and then he unhand customs
to make him apologize no yelling
handcuffed him and left him on the floor
and then they were yelling and screaming
didn't anybody see nothing was gonna
press charges and the whole block was
like no we don't know nothing we don't
know nothing so he got really and he
never friended me he never friend
you know I tried these active on there
yeah but I spoke to other people for my
name and they don't know he never he
just wants to after that day you know
how embarrassing is to see your dad get
beat up
nobody [ __ ] stick up for him yeah but
after that dad became fragile OT know
though because of t know so I was tied
up with karma and he's like oh okay
I won't call you spec yeah I was allowed
to sit on this block and talk to him at
night I go over there at night and sit
there in the summer nights and talk to
him it was a very interesting block list
I was a very interesting reporter Iike
Nelson the pervert the one who would
play football with us to [ __ ] in the
robe all the time he always had a robot
bro
it was the weirdest [ __ ] is the greatest
TV show that's never been made yet I'm
serious Joey this is too good I love how
this all started with talking about
forgiveness to it yeah this is what it's
about it's forgiveness really I've never
forgotten none of those stories I never
forgot that then there's more like when
you bump into people like I talk to Gina
uh I couldn't sister was that Gina lived
on Charles Court I just talked to her
two days ago and she's like are you on
the podcast I want to talk some [ __ ] I
might have a caller Oh that'd be great
yeah I supposed to talk to her and one
of the guys that people took me in there
or he's running for something in town
this this may 5th or something another I
don't know what happened if he wanted
that May night I don't know when the
election is but it's weird that that
well we went down there remember the guy
came out me and Lee went to that
neighborhood we saw him at that street
is completely different that that's at
one time that Street in the summer it
would have 15 kids yeah fifteen thousand
kids yeah and the street over 38th
Street Park there had to be thirty there
in Charles Court had about eight of nine
yeah liberty even the school to the
block where the school was that block
that was a hot block it was the
Mussina's the Canales was called into
the podcast right Cannella he owns the
[ __ ] Horror Show thing rich he ran a
check living on that block but it was a
Deborah musalla that was a that was a
hot block too we had full up up good
times can you talk about I'll cross the
park
the Bolzano blah that was calm my bowels
the hello Carlos Perez the carnies Brian
Carney one time we pissed in a bottle we
put a lid on it and put it back in the
six-pack and he took it out drank the
place hysterical you can't write that
[ __ ] at the stand he was sitting there
for an hour with this piss just drinking
oh man ah hilarious we pissed in the NIP
one of those a times B is this day
anytime you mentioned Brian Carney
drinker gets over the most embarrassing
worst moment of your life is what
they're known for forever didn't drink
its time and he had sisters his [ __ ] you
had the Bender's you had you had so many
[ __ ] people on that block like so
many kids and now you don't see a kid
anywhere no like not even by [ __ ]
accident when you see a kid playing or
talking module one anything and it
breaks my heart it breaks my [ __ ]
leash leave those I never did a lot of
that [ __ ] like I had fun bad [ __ ]
builds a wall out of bricks
I never thought somebody was someone
else's yard what he made the mistake
yeah oh I just left it there they came
back to make a case on the rocks like
what the [ __ ] I just saw bricks with my
dad just feel like Connie just don't ask
any question you have no idea that how
cran then next to them was especially
aus but next to them was an Irish family
that just became friends on Facebook
with the younger kid he was Vitas age
when I was 16 his name was Timmy okay
and he had an older brother who was just
nuts like they had already said at 16 he
had killed somebody like him into Gizzi
hung out like he hung out with a tough
crew that was doing the heroin Wow but
he had a girlfriend
angel and her system with two Italian
girls that were banging do you
understand me banging at fence if I was
12 they were 17 16 yeah that's a hole
and I'll never forget we were at the
soccer field one day just mind their own
business and we heard like hmm oh we
looked over a war in this Maloney that
was the name Timmy and to something
Maloney Brothers
yeah and they had a older brother who
was crazy wild and people knew not to
mess him like he didn't even hang out
her name but he would just walk past us
and look at us like [ __ ] you kids yeah
like you don't know nothing about life
and he was [ __ ] angel he had dug out
like a trench and this side of the Bill
of the [ __ ] hill and they were
hitting they were hidden in this thing
and were up there him one time about
[ __ ] was hairy as [ __ ] he flipped her
over was [ __ ] the doggy style and we
were like 12 our heads were about the
whole hour [ __ ] up like we had never
seen listen in person and that is
craziness this is like the crazy this
had to be like summer of 75 that was
like my craziest summer with those guys
like we had a great great some like that
Samsung gonna say it's like one of those
summers what was hot but I'm gonna
forget that we looked over and we
started giggling like little [ __ ] and
he stopped what he was doing he's like
who was up there he'd come after we read
and then he would see his knees like I
knew was you watching us [ __ ] kill you
[ __ ]
I poked your [ __ ] eyes out and we
would just be like scared I called my
god Timmy Maloney
he ended up OD and a couple years after
my mother
Wow then the old man died but the sudden
the little guys done I finally friended
him on Facebook hey hey you told me I
still remember you Vienna he had a dog
that the dog would just chase rocks and
he would throw tons of rocks and the
dog's teeth you could see with just
Chara didn't have tips from chicken the
dog was tough in that the dog was tough
yeah and I got a dog my dog ran away
killed one of his chickens and his dad
was gonna kill my [ __ ] dog crystal
need it he was a good man Wow it's in an
amazing 40 years later you still
remember every house every kid every dog
that your neighbors had like there's one
neighborhood I remember I remember what
people gave out on Halloween from the
80s Mike oh yeah I came out of full can
of soda I remember certain candy bar
it's weird that you can those memories
last forever I can't forget them I mean
that Who I am today like that whole day
but it will then look at it now it's
like I'm on high alert
like after I go and I make a left on
giving that Terrace I go up to block I
make a u-turn I go back down to pass in
plank road and I make a left on Charles
Court I go a loop I look at all the
houses and it's like just like the
longer therapy yeah like you still see
the people playing before you see the
people walking out of that exactly yeah
rich the hair on my arms to standing up
I did that first of all it breaks your
[ __ ] heart like it breaks my heart
like to you know all the nooks and
crannies you know like that house on the
corner a girl a living fail of there who
was ha hmm
she was 32 7 she had two daughters and
she lived on top and the husband was
like 55 buffet was [ __ ] hot yeah and
she had two French poodles that one of
them was blind so she would have to walk
him across the street in each arm and
she would wear hot pants with a halter
top big fake [ __ ] titties and 70s and
I have them
mind that PHA had a crush on me like
Lily chose Riaz be having stretch on his
feet Oh miss Crabtree you don't have to
call me Norman yeah call me Josie I was
just like that I'm like man she wants me
like I convinced myself that she wanted
so I set up this plan over maybe 13
maybe 12 uh-huh I'm like I'm banging
about tonight because she would walk
over that about 11:00 and he would be
inside he usually he'd stay on the
balcony and watch it so nobody can mess
with her at 11:00 he was old he'd
already be sleeping so I make my move so
I when I went my buddy's got nice and
haman and then like come on come to a
party with my mom I stay home [ __ ] that
I was going to get fake she's a sad late
night tonight is your night bro so if I
tell you I even took like a flower and I
hit the bushes and she came out to walk
the dog with a [ __ ] pair of hot pants
on a halter top and I'm like what the
[ __ ] is this I crawled up behind like a
high face thing Coco how are you and I
go Fay I really wanted you what she said
what are you talking what the [ __ ] are
you talking about
I go fur have such a crush on you and
she's like Coco you drunk you've been
drinking go home please go home and I'm
like starting to crime I love you and
all this [ __ ] and she's like go home but
finally she goes how I let you kiss me
I can't Adi it's wrong the cheek of some
I don't know I really want to touch your
thigh yeah and I touched like a little
bit in between a thigh dog and my dick
blew up like a Goshen I had a run home
would spew coming out of me I ran up
those stairs I had sperm dripping down
my legs oh my god just from touching
earth I came all over myself I was
[ __ ] disgust ha ha and I know her
son-in-law now and I told him we went
for breakfast like last face she
remembers when I hit on it and now she
oh yeah and he she goes you should come
down now
hedonic cuz she's like 70 and she tells
Bobby everyday Bobby I'm hornier than
ever he was she still hot oh she's still
bangable her own son-in-law tells me
from time to time if you want to bang
her you can still come what did her
daughters look like when they had two
beautiful in fact the older daughter
took me to get my ax when I first got my
driving test when I was 17 she drove me
to the guy that [ __ ] that gave me the
license for 50 bucks I don't I reminded
her of that the younger sister's name
was Cathy Cathy's life didn't turn out
that well when Cathy was a beautiful
girl we all grew up thing I could still
see a face a cute little Irish and it
was Cathy carnelli
but she looked really Irish mm-hmm
assisters didi okay but Cathy was young
my age and we grew up together I never
did anything with Cathy and nothing like
that we were like brother and sister
and as we got older she got lost
mmm she really got well she had a
relationship but it just didn't end well
with some guy and then my friend was
banging him and when I went to Colorado
when I came back he goes she's been
asking about you go see it okay and I
walked into her apartment in Union City
right by the police station and she had
on a leopard suit would like crotchless
things like I had heard she had became
like a sex thing like something yeah and
I was curious you know she hadn't ever
[ __ ] me maybe she'd give me a little
stabbing so she's talking to me I'm 21
years old I was in Colorado for eight
months I hadn't seen her in about four
years but we had grown up together right
and it's about 11 o'clock at night but
she tried to blackmail my buddy my buddy
that was [ __ ] him if she tried to
blackmail but then they became friends
afterward okay all right here's the
weirdest thing they became friends
afterward and
he told me she wants to see you so he
dropped me off but he didn't come it
he's like I really I'm not in the mood
to see it okay so I went inside there
and she was expecting me and I went in
we did a couple one and two coke and we
talked but she kept telling me hold on I
gotta go to the bedroom okay and what
was going on was she had a guy back
there that she was [ __ ] she would
disappear for 20 minutes suck his dick
then come back and talk to me and I was
like this had some we hear it was [ __ ]
it was really it was like one old Boogie
Nights saying yeah I just left and never
saw again tell about ten years later I
saw at the track that she had already
had HIV oh man she was really skinny
that was standing with some guys and
they're like stop don't move but I go
watch them they're like Oh Kathy's here
she would go at the end and 93 she was
going to the track hmm and just hustling
Jones at the track oh my god but 10
bucks 20 bucks 50 so sad then they found
her in the car or something like that
supposedly I rest her soul
dead if this cry was thinking about I
mean not any as graphic as that but it's
weird like I used to think I was smart
in school like I did okay cuz I could
memorize stuff and there's people who
I've thought were idiots but it's like
amazing what growing up can do to you
and like now suddenly that person who
you thought was smart is still working
at the high school job and the person he
caught was an idiot the doctor somewhere
it's it's crazy how like you spend so
much time with those people's kids like
you think you know them and you think
you know where their life is gonna go
and people chant I mean people change
yeah it's [ __ ] up it's
it's a very weird life you know and it's
been a great journey and like comedy
like I think about kinda waiting Tempe
this weekend Mike how many times have
you been to Tempe you know and I mean
you're headlining this weekend yeah okay
think about going there as an opener was
pauly to Denver 15 years ago
yeah how good does it feel like
internally like you like oh my god I
used to come to this club and make I'm
not $250 yeah like I used to go to Tempe
and pick up $500 for eight shows yeah
and I was happy to get that bad no plane
ticket you know nothing you had to drive
yourself from California to Tempe six
hours in the car or with the flights
always been 100 each way in Hampi
so you basically made $300 for the week
yeah if you went to tempie if you drove
and had somebody drive you could save a
hundred bucks but that's twelve hours of
your [ __ ] life just pay the extra
yardstick of the line
yeah I'm grateful for all of them yeah
like I I can't believe I got that we
were lucky to make this journey like I
can't believe that it was you me Jim
Norton before he hit and Bobbie Lee in
Vegas in Vegas this is Jim Norton was
just getting on obediently just yeah I
think he was still calling into the show
banjo falling into the show this is how
it started
this is how long I know Steve Simone
yeah it's how long guys and now you're
headlining [ __ ] Denver South yeah I
don't want people to get some for you
not all they haven't used go to Denver
Comedy Works yeah you know I got a promo
code to four tickets if they use the if
they use the promo code nerds they'll
get two-for-one tickets but and it's
Mother's Day weekend I think they wanted
a comedian that you know you could bring
your mom out to the show so that makes
me feel good that makes you feel good
and you do you have you tell these type
of stories only were that leader outlook
yeah last night I went to this thing
from dying up here mm-hmm and some woman
came up to me and she goes you know you
don't know who I am
we were really looking for you a couple
weeks ago we wanted you to come to the
screening of Andre the Giant oh wow
documentary oh you know what I look like
a good a giant but I wasn't really a big
wrestling fan next time and I gave her
your [ __ ] name oh that's the only
thing wrestling you call Steve Simone
and she was laughing she goes okay I
didn't know I don't really know I know
chief Jay Strongbow and mr. Fuji and
yeah you know with the atomic elbow when
I see Jason Roddy Piper told me chief
date Jay Stromberg was really Italian
how great his name was Joe Scarpa rod
Roddy Piper was the greatest he would
tell me all the stories you would have
liked them if you two home was what
Joe's scarf by here look it up look it
up leaf Wikipedia able to see he came
Strongbow yeah that's crazy I really
thought he was a [ __ ] Indian yeah
they used to sing that song I
straightened it chief Jay Strongbow yeah
chief Jay Strongbow they also told me
that mr. Fuji was like a gangster nobody
messed with mr. Fuji backstage he told
me some crazy stories mr. Fuji was
really from Hawaii any ran stuff he was
oh my god what's it say his name was
Luke Joseph Scarpa there you go dad is
cry did not know chief Jay Strongbow
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
I [ __ ] hate when Indians play fake
what's it say Lee I can't read from here
ah
he's dead Joe scarper yeah let's see he
died in 2012 he was 83 Wow
uh Luke Joseph Scarpa born in 1928 was a
wrestler better known by his ring name
chief Jay Strongbow he portrayed a
Native American wrestler who wore a
bonnet who wore a war bonnet to the ring
and would go on the warpath on offense
or see that's not like he look like that
would never be allowed now that's like
the most racist thing is wrestling a lot
to be racist it's not any good now
this was great this was the greatest mr.
food used to throw rice in your eyes hey
blows salt in your eyes close your eyes
it would say like oh he's Pearl Harbor
and I'm baked 70's 80's wrestling was
great
and he used to draw rice into the
audience or something me that something
yeah oh my god Steve Simone you're a
trip with this [ __ ] look at that he did
for 30 years 55 to 80 555 to 85 Wow
I remember him in the early 70s never
mind [ __ ] 55 to 85 yeah Christ
I remember him in the eighties he was
still wrestling the 80s I was doing
drugs I don't know what was going on
wrestling's quick I didn't [ __ ] know
they even wrestled anymore I knew
nothing in himself but now it's just
really weird I brought you on today I
wanted to talk about forgiveness because
you're Catholic and it's everything you
know I really believed in it I thought
that he would show up but he didn't so
and I haven't heard them so now they're
just gonna take it for what it is you
know that's the gift right you forgive
somebody else so hopefully you can
forgive yourself you know and that's I
mean we believe that's that's in our
Creed I believe in the forgiveness of
sins to trust God's music funny because
I took a bicycle to Charles court that
day and I laid it down and I was playing
the one that's Valentine game yeah but I
was just playing and I left the bike
down and that girl I was dry humping
went over and got on the bike
Oh after Valentine the handlebars by
kibosh well she got on the bike so she
was going down Hillary mm-hmm and me and
my friends went around the other way to
catch her then as we ran to catch her
she went to turn on to a sidewalk and
the thing stuck as she went over and
landed on end and then in the neck that
night she got rushed to the hospital
cause she had a blood clot in her brain
yeah God and she lived and she ended up
okay but you know I went over and
apologized for the baggage because no I
know I know they do a human bomb but now
in today's world she's angry empty hmm
why she won't friend me on Facebook you
know then somebody bumped into her
and said you know he's trying he's
looking for issues I don't want to talk
to him again he [ __ ] me up I was a kid
nobody [ __ ] her up man then we were
kids we were [ __ ] playing I never I
know I live with that [ __ ] but I think
however people feel about themselves
that's how they treat others does that
make sense I don't think it has anything
to do with you maybe she hasn't had the
life she wanted to live you know you got
a point brothers how does a confession
work I have no ideas it's the greatest
thing in the world so if you say it and
they do what they say you're forgiven
yeah it's pretty cool well it's pretty
much like our faith is that Jesus died
he took he he paid the bill that we
could never pay oh okay
so when when you confess it's sort of
like you're acknowledging where you went
wrong and the Jews killed them even
though you paid the bill that's when you
know things are back and I'm saying even
though he covered the spread you still
can't stand them [ __ ] the Romans
cameras it was the guineas
it was the guineas next thing you know
he's [ __ ] taking pictures on the
cross [ __ ] poor guy anyway don't
forget to see my little brother Steve
Simone this weekend economy works south
I got dick going on I'm home like I said
May 26 you get the [ __ ] high smirk
out I got a special now it's been coming
soon few [ __ ] and that's it and
that's that life still goes on though it
seems what's up wait Steve Simone's
doing my show on the 15th oh that's
right at the second war time more time
God christina pazsitzky we got Theo von
so that's next Tuesday night Tuesday
night no that's great send me a fun
check I hope we don't have a podcast
let's hope not because we will look at
that Tuesday night I forgot he just
called me for Tuesday night so always
tremendous so that's the way that the
show I had shrimp creole or some shits
last night I went to that [ __ ] I'm
dying up here party you know how is the
food the food was do you know I didn't I
didn't mean
took my wife out to dinner and then we
weren't there just kiss the food sucks
yep but there was a finger food it was
like pigs in a blanket
I love that they had these little what's
the pizza with just a plain like cheese
and sauce they call it like a tomato pie
yeah well Margherita Marguerite had
little Marguerite they were like a
50-cent piece I'm like oh my god I was
eating them that little tamales it was
nice it was nice saying cheetah was nice
seeing Eric Griffin yeah they're good
guys I love that story came in later on
you know I don't say never nobody nobody
yeah person said love me nobody really
talked to me to people yeah I just
talked to my wife the whole [ __ ]
night it was nice to be invited it's
nice yeah get out of me and then I
[ __ ] went and that's it that's how
you do it I usually don't go to those
things but it was a Monday night I got a
baby so that took the wife on a date
it's great yeah it's nice and sometime
you need to do that just a [ __ ]
loosen up the house are you gonna get a
Matisse thing on Sunday I'm not sure you
I'm not good at funerals I know
especially I want to go I've already
made my peace with it yeah so it's just
how I feel on Sunday yeah that's all it
is right now yeah it's just how I feel
or something I think I'm gonna have to
it's Mother's Day
we gotta have to who but down there
there's no Park no parking so hope is
not to be all over the Comedy Store so
I'm not sure yet you know you can't
bring plus-one I know it's gonna be 700
people so the main room is gonna be the
old school and the original is gonna be
the young guys yeah and then they're
gonna the belly room going to and the
belly room going to and they're gonna
have tents outside
700 800 people I know I get social
anxiety around [ __ ] three people at
comedy shows I got I got anxiety onstage
and Tempe last Thursday's idea yeah I'm
not getting into like I had to switch my
flight to fly in for it but I'm still
not gonna be able to get there to like
10 o'clock at night starts at 7:30 I
figured by then most of the people will
be cleared out I'll see Paulie his
brothers hopefully pay my respects and
I'm gonna go straight from the airport
to there and then home and Ari's coming
into town yeah he says he just called
yeah he's staying at my place what is it
called
I think he's getting in Saturday when I
in Denver okay so he's gonna be staying
at my place oh man I'm happy you came on
today thank you I love you those stories
were the best I was feeling guilty about
the Velma thing I know you'd make me
feel a little better but that's it he
just doesn't want me my friend I have to
accept it and move on I've made my
apology I truly see you've amended your
life ya know I had see that see that the
point I don't do a [ __ ] it's gonna eat
me alive I got right read more things I
gotta do now you have to let it go
though I'm done because God forgave you
yeah now you have to learn how to
forgive yourself and then that's it you
move forward as a different person does
that make sense
that's everything a lot of sense
nobody's perfect
alright don't forget Tuesday the
Sycamore tab and don't forget May 20 I
mean we got a lot of dates here but most
importantly Steve Simone economy works
out I love you guys have a great [ __ ]
weekend and I'll see you guys tip-top
Magoo next Monday ready to [ __ ] rocks
they blacked have a great weekend and
you know I love you [ __ ] kicked
this melee